[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
this is the ramsey show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
where he helps people find and do work
that they love every day is my co-host
today number one best-selling author
ramsey personality open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jackson starts the hour off in tampa hey
jackson how are you
hey i'm doing well how are you guys
better than we deserve what's up
yeah um so my wife and i have never
really used an actual budget um we've
always just kind of
we we've got a fairly high income um we
spend what we want and then i've got all
of my investments and everything on
autopilot and so it's sort of just
we just kind of float um and
every every so often i have to pause an
investment or two um to cash flow
something but for the most part it seems
to work um but i feel like we're getting
a little bit financially flabby as we
are
um making a little bit more income and
so i'm just curious
if if an income is uh
kind of goes up and down based on
seasons and things like that how do you
how do you budget um the budget for the
future uh or the money that's coming in
for that month or the money that came in
the past month
okay great question so let me back into
this and start with your last question
first um
you always are predicting this coming
month
and your job there is to give every
dollar
of this coming month's income
an assignment every dollar has a name
that's why we named our app every dollar
and it has become the world's best
budgeting app in the process so you
might want to try it but
um the uh but what you're doing is
you're assigning it's called zero-based
budgeting and we're predicting our
income for the month now
at the beginning of a month
24 hours 48 hours before the month
begins how accurately can you predict
that month's income
it it's tough because what we do is you
run an airbnb business and so
you've got bookings um you got bookings
or you don't that's the first of the
month
we do have bookings but it can it can
increase it can but the vast majority of
your stuff's already on the books before
the month begins dude
uh
i i i would disagree with you in that so
you're saying people don't know
everybody on airbnb rents last minute
no not everybody but i would say percent
of the people do
really i think i could yeah
um
it's it's pretty wild we've been doing
it for about
two years uh that's kind of what we see
okay and that's your whole income
no sir i also have a part-time job where
i bring in about 55 000 okay so that's
predictable and 50 percent of the airbnb
is
is predictable and the other 50 is
somewhat predictable just based on
patterns yeah
yeah like you can say last april i mean
this april last may this may
may generally does this versus february
might be different
because you're probably probably i mean
you're in tampa florida so you know you
probably got some seasonality to the
stuff right
correct yes okay so you can say this
month
i've already got this much on the books
and of the portion that's not on the
books i can predict something so you can
get pretty close you're pretty close to
your income so give every dollar an
assignment now the second thing i would
tell you is this
if you hired someone
to and their job was to manage money for
you
and they manage money for you the way
you've been managing money for you you
would fire them
oh for sure that's why i'm looking to
start all right so it's yeah you need to
get detailed because like i just came
out of budget meetings a few minutes ago
here at ramsey and i was just looking at
the budgets of the different departments
and the different profit and loss areas
and
they're supposed to predict their
revenue and they're supposed to predict
their expenses those people that are
running those areas and if they came in
and said well you know i just kind of
got a feeling i would fire their butt
after a while right i mean
yeah you know so it just wouldn't work
that way so that that's the thing so
you're you're smart to get on top of
this so start treating your
personal finances like a business in
that sense
of it's my job and i look at it as a
christian i go it's my job to manage
god's resources and if i am trustworthy
with those resources i'm worthy of trust
based on my diligence the diligent will
prosper those who are faithful with the
little things will be given more to
manage and so you'll start to dial this
in and get it really get it right and
ken it makes a big difference when
you've got that done as far as the way
you feel well there's no question about
it and the thing that i would say to
jackson is is that budgeting is a skill
you learn to do it better over time i
would start with conservative budgeting
a lot of people get themselves in a lot
of emotional trouble and a lot of
financial trouble when they uh they're
too aggressive on their budget
i would be very conservative
budget way less than you think you know
and learn this process and really dive
in month to month certainly when it's a
business
because it is a skill that you acquire
over time as you begin to analyze the
numbers behaviors the market and you're
going okay every time you miss it you
get a little better at it yeah
absolutely when i was doing your own
personal budget it takes about three
cycles about 90 days to get it down your
first a month you suck yeah and embrace
that yeah embrace it it's going to be a
process it's not going to be it's going
to work it's not going to be easy that's
a good thing and you know what that
brings up a good point too uh being
conservative now that means on if you're
predicting revenue like in his case okay
that 50 that's not booked you know we're
not going to over predict that and be
zealous but we want to be as accurate as
we can the second thing in your personal
budget
everyone out there here's one thing
we've told people for years in financial
peace university and it's very true you
spend more on food than you think you do
that's true
and so whatever you thought you were
spending on food uh when you do your
first budget you're wrong
you're gonna determine you know and if
you put oh we live on 200 no you don't
no you don't that's just bull by the way
it's really easy to do this when you
have two teenage boys i'm learning yeah
14 and 16 dave i'm in uncharted
territory they uh they are they causing
all the food shortage personally
i would say the coleman family there's a
high rate of uh food consumption oh man
these kids i forgot what my brother and
i did to my mom and dad now i'm learning
it's like tapeworms i'm amazed that
people have dialed this in that they
think they truly
believe they're living on less than they
really are right on what you're spending
and another good thing to do with that
food thing because it'll eat your lunch
no pun intended
um
is uh separate when you're first
starting out and this is not doing
jackson's questions just budgeting in
general
separate your restaurants and your
grocery store yes
because i'll give you a wake-up call on
the restaurants like we had one old boy
who came in years ago country boy and
he's sitting there in the small group
we're having a discussion he goes yeah
we figured out where our retirement's
been going we've been eating it
so yeah it's going uh the restaurants i
mean you know it's 1200 bucks a month in
restaurants that guy was spending and
that was that was a long time ago that
story happened
and yeah that that's where yeah why i've
got no money in my kids college fund
yeah i've been going out to eat every
freaking night
and uh cause i'm tired
yeah you know there's all these reasons
but yeah so separate restaurants so you
actually get a real picture of what
you're doing there and food and then
predict as accurately as you can and
jackson start treating this like it's a
business and run it well you have the
ability to do that sir this is the
ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today number one best-selling
author so ken when you're doing your
show what's the most common career
question you are asked these days
it's always around the idea of i think i
know or i know i know where i want to go
but i'm not sure how to get there how do
i scale that mountaintop that
professional pinnacle that's generally
what people are looking for
yeah the path yeah clear power i need a
way to get there a lot of fear and doubt
in that question
yeah i know i need to go over there but
i don't know the map that's right yeah
so guys i need everyone to listen very
carefully we've got a very unique
opportunity where you can have some
focused time with ken
and
ask him your question normally in a
given week we're filtering through
hundreds of thousands of calls
hard to get them all in obviously he
can't take that many on the show
uh this is an opportunity to you know
get a smaller group we're gonna have
about 900 folks in a live stream q a and
um that way that way everybody doesn't
participate but it is going to be
smaller you're going to have more access
you'll be able to plug in and much more
intimate than you know hundreds of
thousands obviously that you're going
through so uh we're going to do a q a
zoom call with ken
and uh and it's you know an exclusive
live stream
group q a
gonna be fun yeah a lot of fun because
what happens is we see that there's a
lot of buckets around these questions
that are easier for people to kind of
lean into as i answer you know tens and
tens of questions here on this and you
get to lean in and take notes and we're
really again addressing this idea of can
i make the money that i desire and also
experience meaning and impact that's
what people want we want to make a
living but we also want to make a
difference and that's what we're going
to be driving in on helping people
make progress to move where they want to
go so if you want to jump in on this
much much smaller zoom situation as i
get as i said what we're going to do is
limit it to the first 900 people there's
no purchase necessary we just want you
to go to ramseysolutions.comkin
use the promo code ken the first 900 to
do that will be part of the zoom call so
one more time ken's going to be doing a
zoom
free no purchase is necessary to sign up
for it no salesman will call all you got
to do is go to the website
ramseysolutions.com use the promo code
ken the first 900 people to do that
starting right now ready set go are
going to be in there and uh you'll get
access to this q a
zoom and it's going to be again a much
smaller setting much more intimate than
just the
the entire freaking world on the radio
that's right it takes the pressure off
right you can you can relax a little bit
in your question and get coached up
without the uh on-air performance which
is hard for people and again it's a zero
cost so just jump in the first 900 of
you ramsey solutions dot com slash can
use the promo code ken and we will cut
it off there we don't want thousands and
thousands of people in this thing
it's just gonna be a few hundred and so
jump in there and right quick and get
that done dan's in hartford connecticut
dan welcome to the ramsey show what's up
hey guys how are you doing thank you for
taking my call sure
um big fan of you dave i've read uh two
of your both financial piece and tony
total money makeover i'm on um entre
leadership right now about halfway
through wow i'm um self-employed myself
um
and uh i got a quick question for you in
being self-employed and you know i made
contributions to my roth into myself
every month
um i know natchez one of the biggest
things i think a lot of people here is
the market constantly going up and down
up and down and i've gotten into i think
the bad habit of checking
my profile uh portfolio every morning
okay and i kind of wanted to kind of get
your
um
take any tips or feedback on having the
minds of just
um not focusing on that as much every
day and kind of just taking a step back
from it's one of the hardest challenges
i have
as a business owner as a as a person
um
only that i have right now is my
mortgage um i wanted but the market is
constantly as you guys know going up and
down it's and it's kind of created a
sense of
uneasiness for me i just want to kind of
get your take on them my mindset on how
to be okay with that
that's a really good question i like
that question
uh i think a lot of people struggle with
this i
i kind of went through the same thing in
a different area
when the book entre leadership came out
years ago is when i got on twitter
twitter was fairly new
and i jumped on twitter was fun in those
days
we would just spar back and forth we'd
have some fun i mean occasionally you
get a troll line we just block them or
first we make fun of them and then we
block them uh but you know i mean we had
a lot of fun with it but but twitter
over the years has just deteriorated and
it's basically a septic tank now
i mean it's a disaster and so but i got
in the habit in those days of checking
twitter uh my tweet deck with all the
all mentions of dave ramsey i would
check it every morning while i was
drinking coffee
and you know when it wasn't bad
that wasn't bad
but when it was bad i had to quit i had
to i didn't take it off my computer i
don't even look at twitter anymore
because it's just it's all nastiness i
don't read i don't read crap every day
and expect my brain to be good
that's one example that comes to mind
second example comes to mind is
um
i uh about three and a half years ago i
decided my wife decided i was gonna
learn how to play golf and now i'm i'm
kind of into it
and i suck
um
and so the uh i have figured out the
secret to golf though the secret to
happiness is low expectations
now
okay
so
the uh
if you don't expect much then it ain't
bad you know so i'm not all torqued out
about it and in that case let's let's
modify that a little bit for your
situation and call it this yeah your
expectation is not to get rich every
morning your expectation is to ride this
investment for 10 or 20 years correct
right right so quit using a tool that
doesn't match your expectation
your tool if you're checking it every
morning as if you're a freaking day
trader
and you're not a doctor yeah you're not
a day trader you're a long term investor
so quit checking it every morning
because you're you're okay the
methodology you're using doesn't match
with
your goal
okay
i love the golf analogy i i gotta jump
on this dan he took us there let me tell
you first of all yeah he doesn't suck
and he's not kind of into it he's
obsessed as any golfer really is when he
when he puts the time into it so i'ma
stay with this this analogy
so for the golfer and i'm now getting to
where dave was about two years ago and i
played yesterday
yeah i practiced for an hour and a half
and then i went and played with myself
and here's what i know when i have a bad
hole dan
i forget it it's the next tee box you
got to forget it and move on any golfer
will tell you that and the goal for me
is not to have a great round yesterday
because that's not realistic
expectations as dave said the goal for
me is to be able to play i'm 47. i want
to play when i'm 67
77 and i want to be better so this is a
long-term deal and investing as well as
getting good at anything or mastering
anything
you have to have the long view not the
short view and the emotions are tied to
the temporary yeah you're putting trash
in your brain
because you're you're reading these
things i don't look at mine every
morning
because i don't have an expectation of
what it's going to do today i couldn't
care less what's going to do all i care
about it does over five years
well it does over 10 years
i mean i wonder about the market
occasionally because a bunch of you
people bring it up but
um but generally speaking i'm
betting that the u.s economy and the
best and brightest companies in the u.s
are going to be worth more 20 years from
today than they are now by the way
there's a track record based on that too
i mean it's 100 yeah 100 of the time but
if you leave it alone 20 years you made
money
in the stock market's history there's no
20-year period of time ever including
the great depression including 0809 07
whatever it was and including you know
you can look at any consecutive 20-year
period of time 100 of them made money
and all you're saying is is home depot
dell
apple
mcdonald's and coca-cola and so on are
gonna as a group be worth more 20 years
from now than they are today are they
going to be worth more in the morning i
don't know what finland is going to do
that's going to affect the economy this
morning nothing i well they might have
i just don't know and i don't care
because i'm thinking long term yeah and
so dan that you get your if you're going
to think long term use a reporting
system that is looking out long term
don't use a reporting system that's
every morning you're driving yourself
nuts
take that off take that little button
off your computer it's right up there in
your taskbar and your favorites go in
there right now and and click remove
click delete
to where it's harder to go i don't have
my mutual funds in my taskbar
they're not in my they're not in my
favorites
and neither is twitter by the way the
golf channel might be no i'm kidding
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money it's a free call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
brandon and brooke are with us in mobile
alabama says on my screen you guys are
debt-free congratulations
thank you thank you dave cool how much
have you paid off
95 000.
wow how long did that take
five months twelve months good and
you're right i'm 25
i'm sorry say again
25 months 25 months i misunderstood i'm
sorry okay
and your range of income during that
time
um around 123 000.
cool what do y'all do for a living
brandon's a police officer and then i am
a secretary and sales assistant for a
hurricane shutter business okay cool
what kind of debt was your 95 000
so
the
we had 37 000 in student loans
we had 16 000 in credit card debt
000 with a car loan and the additional
was our mortgage
no you paid off your house and
everything
we sure did weird people how old are you
two
i am 34 years old i'm 29.
with a paid for house what's this house
worth
uh it's worth 250 000 you guys are so
weird
i love you you're awesome well done
well done okay so how long you been
married
we just got married in july of last year
okay so you started working on this
while you were two singles
yeah well we started we actually started
it when we um started dating was around
the same time we started our dead
journey okay i got to hear this story
how'd this happen
so
brandon has always been more of a
better with money and saving money and i
was not i was the free spirit i guess
you could call us he was the nerd and i
was more of the free spirit and so we
started dating and i and i had some debt
um
and so
he says well i gotta tell you about dave
ramsey and i said okay and so he's like
you gotta read his books i read his book
and so we just talked about it and
he said you know we've got to be on the
same page financially and
so we just started working on it
together and encouraged each other
through the process as we were dating
she makes it sound so sweet
oh yeah that was super simple it sounds
like sweet tea yeah i just that can't be
that easy
it can't be that easy you all had to
have some kind of a fight about it
we really didn't we uh
i i was ready to get out of the debt
i'd always
when i turned 18 it was go get a credit
card because you felt like that was what
you had to do and so i was tired of
living
in that cycle where you pay it off and
you rack it back up and so i was tired
of living in the debt and i was ready to
be free from it and
so we were both on the same page and we
just used that to encourage each other
throughout the process and then when you
get married it goes into high gear right
oh yeah
yeah so i'm just curious how much of the
25 months were you guys dating versus
married
so we started dating in january of 2020
and then we got married last july
so we we dated for roughly i guess it
was about a year and a half
wow and i'm just curious how you we
understand now that it was pretty smooth
sailing as far as emotional and
communication but how did you to help
each other on your separate debts yet
still kind of partnering up together i'm
curious how that worked
so uh what we did was we just
we wrote out our debts he only you only
had the
the mortgage he had the house before
we got together and so i had more of the
debt
i had more debt coming into the
relationship and so
what we did was we
i listed out my debts we
found a debt it's called a candyland
debt chart
and so we printed it out and
laminated them and had them on the
fridge and every time we would put money
we each had our own charts and every
time we would put money towards debt
while we were dating we would color in
blocks
to keep us on track as to how much we
were paying off
very cool good for you guys how does it
feel to be a hundred percent free and
newly married
amazing
absolutely amazing very cool very cool
and i see a couple of little boys in the
uh i think it was two little boys in the
in the youtube pictures we saw popping
up is that right
yes sir those are mine um for my first
marriage bentley is seven and then
beckham is six and then we have a new
edition coming at the beginning of july
oh all right very cool good good so the
boys were in on all this i assume they
were and we actually
since we started this whole process
brandon wanted to get them involved so
that they can learn from a young age
the things that we didn't know as kids
and so
we read the smart money smart kids book
and we have currently got them on the
chore flash envelope system
and we've also started teaching them
about taxes budgeting and saving
oh man you guys are this is a complete
change of everything way to go guys
very well done you've changed your whole
family tree
yeah they're super excited we told them
they were with us during the whole
paying off debt and we told them that
once everything got paid off we were
going to take a trip to disney so we're
going to disney in november all right
there we go with a new baby of course oh
yeah
all right you guys are fun very very
well done i'm so proud of you great job
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um just don't give up i know it sounds
cliche but don't
surround yourself with positive people
who will encourage you because we had a
lot of people that
kind of rolled their eyes at us when we
didn't want to spend extra money or we
were watching what we were spending to
put towards debt and
i would also tell people to do the debt
snowball i tell people that all the time
it worked don't question it just do it
and then just find ways to get creative
on saving money i mean you know we were
dating during a lot of this and so
yeah it would have been fun to go do
these expensive things but we were also
trying to pay off debt so we had to find
creative ways for date night
yeah
very cool good job y'all well done
well done what was the toughest thing
you went through
i think the hardest part for me
was
just at the very beginning
coming to terms
basically
getting head on with my debts and
writing them all out
and accepting like you've got these
debts you've got to get control of it
and then
being transparent with this guy that i
just started a relationship with and
hoping he wasn't going to just run the
other way so i think that was the
hardest part for me and just
it's just changing my mindset you know
getting into a new mindset
of you know you really do you've got to
completely turn your life around and
make the change or it will consistently
be like this the rest of your life
brandon i don't think you were running
anywhere
no i was not
at the very beginning not a chance well
done you guys we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that's the
next chapter in your story for sure
and also a copy of total money makeover
for you to give away and we also are
going to throw in financial peace
university in every dollar in a ramsey
plus membership a one-year membership
free we're going to send that to you and
if you don't need it yourself you can
give away any of these items and pay it
forward and help somebody else out
certainly the total money makeover book
is for that to help somebody else and
get moving in the right direction so way
to go you guys very
very very well done all right brandon
and brooke in mobile alabama 95 000 paid
off in 25 months making 123 000 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
ready three
two one
[Applause]
[Music]
got the boys involved i love it
that's how it's done
oh man
you know the interesting the correlation
between this and changing your family
tree is all the indicators are there
they're going to continue on
because it wasn't just merely a single
item that they worked on the debt they
transformed everything the way they're
looking at transform the boys
everything everything's changed and that
means they're going to go on and be baby
steps millionaires yeah this is the
ramsey
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five westin's in
phoenix hi weston how are you
i'm doing great thanks for having me on
sure what's up
so i am uh really excited getting
married to one of my dreams in uh
september
and we are gonna rent for the first year
of marriage however uh looking at buying
property instead of buying a house
and
the reason being my dad is a general
contractor so we have a general contract
license we can use i've had experience
in construction industry
i am also self-employed so i have
autonomy to be able to work on the house
a little bit differently than anybody
else but um when it comes to the
financial side
uh
if we buy land we can't get a
traditional financing on it uh banks
don't like to lend on raw land so
what i'm trying to figure out is should
we
pull from um
we have 32 000 in cash reserves uh
starting to save for the property
however looking about and hundred
thousand dollars or more to buy property
you'll be fine
you'll be fine what are you making here
so combined income we will make uh about
a hundred and five thousand a year okay
okay you can get a credit union loan you
a hundred thousand are loaning you fifty
thousand on a hundred thousand dollar
property you can get fifty percent down
twenty-five percent down somewhere in
there and get somebody to loan it
um
you know bank of america doesn't do it
but bank of america is stupid don't do
business with them anyway
okay so go to your go to your local
credit union your small town bank find
somebody like that a local or regional
bank but primarily or uh if you can get
a community bank or credit union that's
your best bet but they'll loan money on
raw land but again they're gonna want 50
percent down 40 down something like that
well that's that's kind of the problem
because we may i when i say 100 000
that's probably a little bit low that
the housing market
land market here in phoenix and uh take
your time if you want if this is the
route you want to go it may just take
you a little while to save up the down
payment because it's going to be a
substantial down payment
my question is is would it be better to
take so
my fiance has a roth um with 19 000
which we could take 10 000 out
absolutely not absolutely not
new okay
that's a bad idea even even if the cost
of capital is going to be more expensive
than the rate of return especially that
roth is going to grow completely
tax-free and you're in your 20s
you're going to cost yourself millions
of dollars screwing around with your
roth and what it would turn into when
you're in your 60s
okay so that's a bad idea
it's a really bad idea yeah leave your
roth alone and save up and pay cash for
it i'll add to this okay just as a
practical thing
i've built a couple of houses in the
last few years
uh in the last 15 years i guess i bought
built two houses
and um we were already married many
years and it already uh
experienced several marital storms where
we almost killed each other prior to
trying to build a house together and in
other words we have a strong marriage
and a seasoned marriage that's been
tested battle tested and we still
gotten some major fights building those
houses
so it's a stress on your marriage
uh or she's gonna do something really
stupid which is say nothing and let you
do whatever you wanna do and that's a
dumb idea and she might do that as a
young wife
old wives seldom do that
so
but yeah uh
you know i i might buy something and
live in it
and make the uh build my house on a
piece of land the second step
if i were in your shoes just to make
sure you guys are on the right page and
all this kind of thing i don't doubt
that you and your dad know how to build
a house that's not and that you've got
access to time to work on it i think all
that analysis is correct i'm a little
bit
afraid of you know of a young tender
marriage and the damage it could do to
build a house together
you can either run over her and she gets
nothing and you just go bill whatever
you want to build which is a bad idea or
you're going to go through some stress
which is a bad idea so building a house
together is
it's just not always pleasant
unless one of you just says whatever you
want to do honey which is also dumb
and um
and you know sharon's like well you're
not gonna let me i'm not gonna let you
i haven't ever let you do anything
right that's not that isn't even how
your brain works honey the truth she's
been waiting on me to give her
permission so she
but yeah it's getting you know what what
she's saying is you won't go along with
what i wanted that's what she's saying
right so it can really
i mean it it's tough enough just to pick
out a house together but building one is
stressful
yeah you know i think about that and i
go you start thinking about the early
parts of life and maybe building a house
forget the relational strain for a
moment but just what you want there's
something to be said for living in a
house first
before you build a house there's some
just practical stuff what you think you
want initially may not be what you want
five to seven years from now yeah and
and you know yeah things change that's
for sure dreams change
uh sharon's with us in washington dc hi
sharon how are you
sharon
hello hello
yes i can now how are you
oh wow great i'm doing great how are you
good how can we help
well um
i
uh and i've been on a job um
well i'm 56 years old
and
i got a new job in
in 2020
and
it just has not been what i thought it
would be so i went on and started
applying for new jobs um i really wanted
to get another job in addition because
sometimes you know just having another
job that you can do makes you put up
with the other one
well plus i wanted a bigger shovel so
um
i applied for a job
and um
i did accept it through an agency though
so it's not full-time in contract to
hire
now that is um
they send me the paperwork employee
packet etc
um something
made me want to just okay let me check
out the company
that i am going to be looking for i went
through 10 or two interviews with them
by the way and that was fine so they're
going to hire me but um i said let me
start looking into them a little bit
more because
they've only for 20 years that company
that is um and also
um
when i pulled them up again they had all
these bad ratings and they had bad
ratings on
yelp and google and glassdoor and better
business your last door is absolute crap
nobody puts they don't they don't screen
anything anyone can write anything on
there even if they never worked for the
company they don't check anything they
don't they don't source any of it it's
complete crap
okay well i checked the company i
currently work for too and if they're
readings weren't that bad so but anyway
um
now i'm not sure if i'm just getting
cold feet or what but then i also want
to uh
i say well how were their earnings last
year so when you can look up these
things online and appear that they have
lost quite a percentage from the
previous year
and uh the ceo said they were
disappointed and everything so we are
wondering oh my gosh what kind of
company am i signing up for
and uh
and
and so i'm kind of wondering what i
should do i have a creepy feeling
when i i started seeing all of this well
you got to listen to that sharon you got
to listen to that but this is part-time
this is a part-time deal correct
no this is um
no it would be a full-time job so okay
so you're looking at it or i'll be
making more on an hourly because it's
contract higher so i do get some
benefits like insurance from the agency
but it's contracts are higher and so i
get 75 an hour so it comes about you
know 145. all right well here's here's
higher than my full-time job
you need to run these doubts out and get
them out of your head and write these
doubts down and it's not just well i
heard bad stuff on these websites you
got to do a little bit more research
you're right on the cusp of this but i
would trust your gut
your gut that gut feeling neuroscience
has found out that that's a real thing
that's your brain telling your body
stop i would listen to the doubts i
would run them out and get real evidence
and then i would be okay saying pass
just because it's a better paying job
doesn't mean it's the right job for you
and never make an employment decision
based on anything on glasgow
right this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for hanging out
open phones again triple eight eight two
five five two two five starting this
hour off is j in los angeles hi jay how
are you
hi dave i'm well how are you better than
i deserve what's up
um i'm kind of new to your teachings um
but i'm actually not far off like when i
look through like your steps
i'm very close like baby step adjacent
i'm right there okay but
i was working on baby step six before i
kind of got locked into what everything
you were saying but just to kind of walk
it back a couple
i've had 15 going into my retirement
already
but i'm not sure
like the percentages i have going in i'm
not sure if it makes sense so my company
does a regular 401k
and they also do a lot 401k
i randomly just had like 12 going into
the regular when they'd also do the five
percent match and i had three percent
going into the loss
and i have no idea if that makes sense
or if i should change that i just kind
of want to get your feedback on that
okay
well let's just use some some round
numbers okay if you were going to as an
example
compare putting 15 of your income into
traditional
versus 15 of your income
into roth
okay
it takes more of your income to put 15
into roth because it's after tax
but you're still putting the same amount
of dollars in does that make sense
yes
but it's technically after tax so you're
gonna have uh you know more of a tax
bill in other words
uh by doing the roth but if you said
okay i'm gonna put
fifteen thousand dollars because i make
a hundred thousand into a traditional or
i'm gonna put fifteen thousand into a
roth roth is always better because it's
going to grow 100 tax-free
and when you get to retirement
95
97 of what is in your account will be
growth it will not be what you put in
and so that growth being taxable or
being tax-free is a big deal meaning if
you got like two million dollars in your
401k at retirement you're going to have
a 500 000 tax bill on that traditional
and a zero tax bill on that roth
so the way we figured out the math is
this
in actual fact not in theory
uh the the match is the best thing you
can do but very few people have a
hundred percent match
uh most people that have a 401k have
some kind of match so you take the match
first because that's a hundred percent
rate of return on your money
instantaneously
then beyond that i'm going to do roth
because it grows tax-free
if i run out of roth and i've still not
gotten my 15 in match and
roth then i'm going to do traditional
because you want that
tax-free growth is better than tax
deferred growth
to the tune of 250 000 per million
which is a big deal it's a lot of money
so that word roth is worth you know 100
000 a letter
something like that no i've never even
thought about it that way
i mean i wish if i was going to have
something named after me
senator william roth yes they got that
legislation passed what a wonderful
thing to have named after you that
people actually got to keep their
freaking money
and it's got your name on it that's a
pretty cool thing it's very one of the
few deals out of the federal government
um
and it's in an irony that the irony of
it is we get to keep our money that we
earned and that's a deal yeah we're
grateful for it and we're supposed to go
whoo that's a deal yeah it is a deal but
i mean and of course senator roth has
passed away but what a wonderful legacy
to have something that positive named
after you
debbie is with us debbie is in eugene
oregon hi debbie how are you
hi mr ramsay hope you're doing better
than you deserve always
if you don't believe me ask people
i have a husband who has a gambling
problem and um
just can't overlook it anymore and
i don't know what to do i
i don't know what to do i'm you new to
your program i i actually found you
through him
um and uh
haven't started the baby steps yet but i
have been watching as much as i possibly
can
on shows especially pertaining to
gambling um on youtube and uh
i'm sorry
how long you all been married huh
36 years
[Applause]
well
there are a lot of problems here
and um i'm not gonna give you a lot of
good news but i'm gonna give you a lot
of truth okay
okay
i've worked with addicts my entire
career
because 100 percent of addicts have
financial problems
that's truth number one
and the truth number two is you can not
fix enough hide enough twist enough
to beat this
the gambling addiction is going to
win
you can't beat it
okay i'm seeing that yeah you can't how
do i budget when he's a gambling addict
you can't how do i have retirement how
do i build wealth you can't
because the addiction
feeds and sucks the blood out of
everything in the house
and uh whatever the addiction is in this
case gambling
so um
what i'm telling you is is that you
really only have one option for a
prosperous future and that is to address
the addiction with him
and demand
that he get some help
and if he doesn't if he doesn't then he
is making the choice to separate himself
from you
okay
because i
you know you're there's nothing you can
do
that is big enough powerful enough to
offset the amount of stupid an addict
can do
and he's scared he's broken he's stuck
and you say i love you i'll walk with
you but we're going to walk out of this
we're not going to walk along acting
like this sitting here
because one hundred percent of the time
five to ten years from now you're going
to have lost everything
your house
all your retirement
your kids college fund
you're gonna get lied to
you're gonna be manipulated
it's going to get worse or it's going to
get better
and that depends on you and on the
choices he makes from today forward
and so are you guys by chance plugged
into a good church
um i am uh he's not he
uh refuses us when we have talked about
help he you're right he is broken he is
scared
but he refuses to get help of any kind
and years ago we tried gambling
anonymous and he only learned cameras
anonymous works
it works
and treatment with a counselor works
doing nothing doesn't work
and if i'm if if it's my spouse i'm
going to say i'm going to walk with you
but i'm walking out the door if you
don't fix this if we don't go to work on
it
because honey ain't going to be anything
else there's no middle ground with these
guys
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
um
[Music]
well it's officially event week we are
so excited we'll be doing our building
wealth live
event this thursday in orlando
if you haven't gotten your tickets yet
what are you waiting for we want you to
come see us there's going to be over
3000 folks there completely jam-packed
almost sold out
right at the edge we just came back a
couple weeks ago from doing one of these
in las vegas it was a lot of fun about 3
000 folks at that and it's going to be
ken coleman dr john deloney
george campbell rachel cruz and me
ken and john will be doing a bonus
session
about work and about relationships to
kick it off and then we'll do the main
event uh that'll feature all of us
and we want you to be there we're gonna
be talking to you about really building
wealth in this crazy world
all the stuff that's going on
everybody's got an opinion out there but
we're going to walk you through exactly
what millionaires do
not theory
proven points of data of exactly what to
do
to build wealth the quickest
easiest way to become a baby steps
millionaire the one that actually works
in other words see if you have to do it
over and over again it takes longer
i know because i lost everything once
and got the opportunity to start again
i'm so stupid i've done it twice
so uh there you go this millionaire
stuff so orlando this thursday and then
in the fall we'll be in phoenix
sacramento minneapolis and san antonio
those are all
for
75 sold out already
now you can get your tickets for 25 each
you can get a four pack of tickets
starting as low as 60 dollars bring your
friends it's going to be amazing so you
and your spouse bring another couple
with you it's only 15 bucks ahead i mean
come on seriously gonna be a lot of fun
we'll be signing books and taking
pictures and everything afterward
building wealth this thursday
in orlando the uh crowd in orlando ken
is going to have to get with it to uh
keep up with the folks in vegas they
were on fire it really was an electric
room all of our events are a lot of fun
you don't just get equipped it's an
entertaining night uh and you know what
it was so fun is the after the event to
get out in the lobby and see people
shake hands high five sign books take
pictures it was wonderful just to see
people again meet them where they are
because it's fun to speak to them um but
it's really fun to meet them as well and
that's a special uh feature as well you
know
it turns out that we do shake hands now
yeah we always did but for the record we
never stopped i know but people oh yeah
people yeah everybody's people yeah you
know and and
you know uh we we're
like
normal human beings and everything yeah
and so uh
you know i remember a thought a couple
of years ago people said well we'll
never shake hands again
i said well i don't know about that
i might go further and shake your hand i
might just hug you yes completely make
sure that you get grossed out yeah
that's right but the uh so i mean human
beings need other human beings and uh
and we need connectivity we need
presence uh and there's something about
being at a concert that's different than
listening to the album
there's something about being at one of
these events that's different than
reading the book or listening to the
radio show
and so come on out it inspires you it
moves you along the process helps you
move in the right direction and that's
what we want to do
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five will is in
richmond virginia hi will how are you
hi dave and ken how you all doing today
better than we deserve sir what's up
awesome well thanks to your program we
are in baby step seven uh but i am going
through an extended medical treatment my
wife's job is a 1099 job with no
retirement benefits and i can't do my
regular job now so i can't contribute to
my 401k
we do have some income but we're trying
to figure out if we should continue to
contribute to our
roth iras or just keep the money in cash
in case this treatment doesn't work out
i'm trying to minimize any difficulty
that my wife and kids would end up
having or possibly having
accessing the money in my retirement in
case the worst happens
uh what's your thoughts wow what's
what's wrong will what are you getting
treatment for
um multiple myeloma uh
cancer plasma cancer
ouch
yeah yeah i've been out of work i i'm
i'm i've been out of work i'm recovering
from surgery um
at this point right here the prognosis
is good
but i'll be getting
a transplant and it's going to keep me
out of work for
probably another
three or four months a bone marrow so
not bone marrow actually
stem cells they're going to harvest some
of my stem cells
uh pack them in the freezer for a while
and then we're gonna uh you know the you
probably heard the process where they go
in and do the stem cell transplant here
wow
how old are you
uh 54.
well you sound pretty upbeat and chipper
so um uh i've you've kept you're
absolutely blessed you kept your
attitude yes
which is uh as i hear i hear the rumor
that that's a lot of fighting it is
attitude
so yes uh it's the only shot you got
anyway so you might as well try it
um man that's awesome well i'm glad
you're working your way through this
uh
the answer is either one's okay i want
you to spend all your energy on beating
cancer
uh i don't really care where the money
is you can pile it up a big old pile in
the corner of the bedroom if you want i
don't care
but i probably wouldn't but
but uh uh i mean if you put it into a
money market it's still gonna be there
but if you put it into a roth ira and
your wife is the beneficiary on the roth
ira she has no trouble accessing it go
straight to her if you passed
okay instantaneously it's outside of the
estate it has nothing to do with
probating the will or anything
oh okay well that's even better yeah you
name a beneficiary on your retirement
accounts and it goes straight to the
person it's not it's not up for grabs
it's not a it's not up for somebody
wanting to sue and say it's not in the
will doesn't matter
it's beneficiary beneficiary old trump
card that's it they get it it's like
life insurance the beneficiary gets oh
okay beneficiary gets it straight away
like minimum distributions isn't going
to be a problem doesn't have anything to
do with it no it's it's an inherited
iras different rules
oh okay
all right well that's awesome that's
exactly what i was looking for then so
either way is a good way yeah i i think
i'm probably going roth if i'm you
because it works if you make it and it
works if it doesn't make it
yep
you know and i mean if this this works
out then you know we don't we just keep
working the plan and
okay all right yeah it doesn't it
doesn't leave her it doesn't leave her
in a lurch if something happens to you
do you have life insurance
oh yes good good how much yeah
um
i think mine is 250 000 because i had
some medical issues before i got the
policy how long you been married in
uh
15 years
how's she doing
she's doing great okay she's doing great
she's uh she's been i haven't been able
to do anything i can't i can't drive
like she has to take care of you know
he's just driving everywhere
um so um
she's just been a trooper through the
whole thing and still doing her job and
we've got two you know i got two
teenagers
all right i want you to call me in five
years and tell me you beat it okay
absolutely all right man absolutely look
forward to hearing from you god bless
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five see personal
finance involves cancer and gambling
addictions yeah
life happens right in the middle of your
money
yeah it does these these things that we
teach do not happen in a vacuum
where everything where you live in some
little unicorn perfect world with
skittles
and you know it's interesting we heard
the wife of the of the gambler he's
scared
um shaken confused and then we hear the
voice of this man who has cancer is
fighting for his life and he's got peace
it's pretty interesting stuff and a lot
of that has to do with his financial
situation plus just his personal faith
and the way he's lived his life it
really is spiritual yeah i mean he's
facing a real battle there and he has
tremendous confidence and just
blessed is what he said
what a difference that contrast is
fastest growing addiction right now in
america online porn
second fastest growing addiction online
gambling
and you guys that are using up your
family's money playing sports book and
you think you're cute you're not a
freaking teenager
be a man and don't screw up your life
get some help
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage andrew
and shannon are with us hey guys how are
you we're doing great we're so excited
to be here thank you so much for having
us we're honored we're excited to have
you where do you guys live we live just
outside of houston near john delonia's
area in santa fe texas well you're
welcome anyway
[Laughter]
john deloney's area he's now renamed
houston to the john dolone area that's
power right there hey guys how much debt
did you pay off about 57 000
awesomeness and how long did that take
well it mostly took about 14 months okay
and your range of income during that
time started at about 64 000 and at
about 120. whoa nice doubling what do
y'all do for a living um andrew is
active duty coast guard
and i am a financial administrator at
arcadia first baptist church cool thanks
for your service andrew thank you good
stuff what kind of debt was this 57 000
well about 34 000 was my student loans i
had a little bit of bachelor's degree
and my mba in accounting and then we had
about 17 000 in a truck and
about a little over four thousand
dollars in credit cards okay you were
kind of normal a little bit um
we've always tried to keep our budget on
his but
let me tell you it's been a roller
coaster it's a thing and how long y'all
been married we've been married for
almost 17 years very cool okay so
something changed dramatically about a
year and a half ago what happened well a
little bit farther back than that we had
an our our had it moment we were just
done with putting our money everywhere
else and we
were just tired of it and so finally we
actually watched the reset of 2021 and
that's when we put all our chips in and
we're like we gotta finish this because
i'm done just dragging this out
so we had a little bit in savings and so
we put that on the truck and that just
helped our that snowball just roll and
go faster and faster and faster and i
started at this job back in august so
it totally made a huge difference in our
income yeah like doubled it yeah it made
a big big difference so that helped us
just really go towards the finish line
very cool why'd it go you guys so you're
kind of messing around the edges of it
but then reset said okay reset exactly
we're after covered we're going exactly
all right excellent i like it very good
and 14 months later you're done
absolutely it took you 17 years to do
that 14 months yeah we he we had some
stupid and
hey i've done a lot of it so i know what
it looks like good for y'all i'm proud
of you very well done
well i got to ask a question because i
get this a lot on the ken coleman show
people go hey i want to change jobs but
i'm in the baby steps can i do it and
you are the model you change jobs
leveled up big time during the baby
steps i want you to speak directly to
those people who are scared of that what
would you say to those people if you
were having lunch with me absolutely
that was listening to you can was a big
big big change for me um i was working
just trying to get the best next job and
i'm like i need to know my worth i need
to take time for myself and and really
get to know myself and then
god really just the holy spirit brought
me to this church and it really
it changed our lives forever and i'm so
grateful for it um
he
was so funny he took me in
you know
three different directions eight minutes
north of my house eight minutes south
and then finally eight minutes west and
that's where
i work every day and i love it i have
the best team
and having the best work culture it has
ruined me forever but i love it i love
where i work and having that sweet spot
is absolutely the best way to describe
it i'm right exactly where i need to be
doing exactly what i want to do
so that's awesome so it is possible you
can't change jobs while paying off debt
absolutely in fact you know especially
when you get a raise hello that's the
whole point right it made a huge huge
difference good good for you so praise
god for that yeah well done all right
andrew so your uh accounting
wife
yes sir comes walking in and goes okay
game on or did you say cut or game on or
how did this work out she had been
talking about it and hinting at it and
we were on a road trip and we're talking
about finances and
i was just watching all of our money go
in all of our money go out and i just i
was tired of it
i was just done so you're ready i'm out
of here i'm done yes sir this is it
we're changing this thing yes yeah very
cool and now we're teaching our kids you
know this is we don't go into debt this
is how we do our life you know if you
don't have money in your little you know
savings account you're not spending it
amen there we go gosh i hope those kids
are congressman someday
[Laughter]
they're too smart for that
well done you guys well done what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is i think my biggest thing has
been self-control when rachel talks
about putting it in the cart and just
like leaving it there
that's been
the biggest thing is just not to press
you know the cart button
but that self-control has really been
the biggest key and communicating
every little teeny tiny thing even if
you're just getting a pack of gum right
you know it's like
it's just being on the same page on
everything is so so big that's a big
deal
well very well done you guys we're proud
of you excellent excellent job good
stuff who are your biggest cheerleaders
um we kept it kind of quiet um we had
some people like oh you can't do that i
mean how many times you hear that yeah
that just spurs you on right oh exactly
let me prove you wrong right um we his
mom was a really big cheerleader she's
been listening to you for years and
um just i have really great co-workers
that have just been like yes you can do
this and yeah it's just just trying to
surround yourself with positive people
has just been a game changer yeah
well good job you guys very very cool
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure thank you so much you're
going to be millionaires now yes sir
that's pretty cool i'm ready
it's on the way i can see it it's in the
math
and uh also a copy of total money
makeover for you to give away and stir
up a ruckus with somebody when they hear
your story they're gonna know how you
did that and you say read this yeah
we've already passed it on and we thank
you so much well thank you and we've got
a copy of uh we're also gonna give you a
gift card for every dollar and financial
peace university as a part of the ramsey
plus subscription for one year thank you
and uh you can give that away or you
guys can go back through it or you can
lead it or do whatever you need to do
life is good proud of you guys thank you
all right what are the kids names and
ages we have the oldest he's 15 this is
james and the middle is what and he's 12
almost and this is thomas he's seven
and um
let me tell you about the grocery bill
ken oh yeah you're just getting started
wait till these two guys here get into
teen years and they're all playing
football oh my goodness oh that's good
yeah that means they need that means
they're going to put on boys more steak
and more milk
you okay you just up their grocery bill
can oh they can afford it they're
debt-free i like it all right andrew and
shannon james wyatt and thomas from
houston texas john dalone country 57
thousand dollars paid off in 14 months
making 64-120
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
one
two three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is so interesting
i've had a front row seat you've had a
front row seat for decades now watching
people change their lives
and it's just you know you go along
15 years of marriage and then a year and
a half ago they said
yep no more yeah no more we're not going
to live like this anymore and they just
made a decision
and uh you know shannon's got all the
accounting background andrew's got the
military discipline
and you know we're just gonna we're not
doing this anymore
and we just decided
and so if you've been married 25 years
you can decide
starting right now ready set go you've
been married 25 minutes you can decide
ready set go right now
right now
the point is if you're hearing this at
this moment
this means it's your moment
now yeah i'm talking to you
right
now
you can decide to change your life
but i can't decide for you
or i would have already done it
you have to do it
[Music]
you
get to decide
you're free
you get to decide to stay stupid
or change
we all make these choices
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today justin is in waco hi
justin how are you
pretty good dave how are you and now ken
doing today better than we deserve sir
how can we help
well i appreciate you guys taking my
call um and appreciate your service for
what you guys do out there and um just
to take a little bit of time to talk to
me today um i'm gonna try to articulate
as best as i can
the question i have but basically we um
we found a home last september
in the area and it was just a lot and it
was um
they're going to be built up with a um a
custom home a local builder here not too
big
and uh here we are today nearly seven
months later and um
we're right at the end where we're
supposed to close
and
sign closing documents tomorrow
but
the house is not yet 100 complete nor
have you know has has a certificate of
occupancy been issued to the house
and so
the realtor and the uh the lender i'm
dealing with you know everyone just kind
of i feel like there's a lot of
miscommunication with the builder they
just got the appraisal last friday so
i'm just wondering for the sake of my
myself my wife and my two kids
we had been supposed to we were supposed
to close last month but we've been
pushing it pushing it pushing it now we
are you know completely out of our uh
prior lease and staying in a hotel in
the hopes of closing this week should i
go and sign the closing documents even
though the house i mean there's still
some work to be done from what i can see
it's not got the ceo yet so i don't know
if that made sense what's it take to get
a co
where you can move in
um basically like the
you know the mechanicals the hvac
those those issues um
from what i can see in the united states
that didn't make sense you're telling me
it doesn't have hvac
no it does it does have hvac you you um
in terms of what it takes to get a co
that's my understanding is so
interesting
basically yeah and they need to seal the
floors there's concrete floors in the
house to get a ceo so
basically yeah i guess that's a finished
floor that counts as a finished floor so
yeah but i'm not sure they have to i
mean i don't depends on code i guess but
um what i want to know is exactly what
it takes to get a co and when that's
going to be completed
they say that it's supposed to be
completed wednesday but i mean
if you've got a co then you close
okay
now how much other work non-ceo required
work is outstanding
there's
uh a sun room that's attached to the
house a glass paneled sunroom um
that he said would be done last weekend
but it's getting pushed to next weekend
he says
um
there's just little minor work on what's
the total price of the house
352
okay what's the sun room worth
um 12 000.
okay
all right
so uh if you can get a co you're ready
to close now as far as the other repairs
go
standard procedure would be to escrow
money until he gets the work done
that you hold out of the proceeds fifty
thousand bucks until he gets this fifty
thousand dollars worth of miscellaneous
stuff done and then it would be released
to him
that's what the lender said exactly yeah
that's standard
i got no problem with that i would not
close until you got a co though
okay
because the problem is the problem is
that if you close
and it's six months before you get a co
what the crap are you gonna do
yeah that's that's what i i just have
never been in this situation before
we've dealt with a prior builder that
was you know a larger builder you know
throughout
north america where this this house has
just been totally different you know we
haven't done a walk through yet so i
just
i don't know i just want to kind of
protect myself and yeah it sounds like
they need to put the closing off another
week
okay get the co get a walk through and
establish the amount that you're going
to hold in escrow for the non-co repair
items
okay punch list stuff if it's minor
punch stuff and you trust the guy you
don't worry about it but it sounds like
you got some major punch going on here
i yeah i i don't know it sounds like
he's
yeah i really don't know but yeah i
think maybe you're right maybe holding
off another week you know to let them
knock out some more i mean if you can
get it all done by wednesday a co a walk
through the escrow amount established
you can still do it i don't care if you
do it but i've got a feeling that co's
not going to be done wednesday based on
the way you're hesitating and moving and
you don't think it's going to be done
wednesday
i mean that's what the builder said but
like i said this has been you know
ongoing um you know uh for just i know
that these things these things can be
delayed but it's we're supposed to close
april 16th and
we're in we're in may but if i can maybe
finagle him to to do it all on wednesday
that'd be great because i mean like i
said we're in a hotel we're kind of in
limbo and i just don't want it for long
i don't mind you moving in i don't mind
you moving in with a punch list in an
undone sun room i want to escrow some
money for all of it
uh because i want his uh feet held to
the fire to get the work done
yes sir okay and uh but but the co man i
mean you can't move in it and you're
paying payments on it after you close it
exactly that's what my understanding was
of closing so yeah as soon as you close
it you get the clock the clock starts
ticking on the old payments brother
so yeah we're not gonna be paying
payments on something that's not got a
ceo that can't live in
okay
all right well that gives me some more
confidence no co no clothes
once there's a co
you can work out the walk through you
can work out the escrow and then you can
close and that might be wednesday it
might be thursday it might be friday it
might be next wednesday i don't know
depends on that but you just tell the
builder
no co no clothes
yes sir
thank you very much god bless you guys
thanks man sorry for you sorry you're
facing this it's a lot of stress
and you moved out of his house oh god
well and the problem is stuff like glass
is still in you know you're still having
trouble getting it
it might be four months yeah before he
gets it yeah
and so yeah i mean i don't mind that if
your sun room isn't operational that's
first world problems right can't live in
the house
that's another thing yeah right i mean
it's a different thing but sheesh
it's uh this is all about supply chain
and labor yeah uh unless the builder's
just a bad guy but i think it's probably
supply chain and labor
all right bo's with us in san antonio
hey bo what's up
hey how are you dave better than we
deserve how can we help
all right so my question is
with my family are looking to buy a
house
right
um so we have a pretty good emergency
fund at twenty thousand
we have about twenty thousand saved dogs
um we don't have it yet and
you're not your phone's breaking up
you're gonna stand still and speak
direct into it we can't hear you
okay can you hear me now yeah sure
okay good deal um so like i said
you know we own a camper we've seen that
and we got three little ones
um but there's four beds and
it's comfortable living you know but my
question is is is it the right time to
buy a house
with like inflation in the economy going
the way it is and also
i work in the oil field so my pace
fluctuates a little bit like
around
200 and then on the low end
4200
yeah well they're going to go if you're
in the oil field they're going to go off
your w-2 if you're paid on a us payroll
uh the mortgage company is if you're not
and you're on a 1099 they're going to go
off your tax returns
and two years average of your tax
returns they don't care about the
monthly fluctuation
they're looking at what did you make in
the year what'd you make in the last two
years by the year
and that'll qualify you for the mortgage
or not as far as whether it's time to a
good time to buy a house it's a wicked
weird time to buy a house that's for
sure uh and a lot of weird things going
on but you can you know as long as you
don't get caught up in the fever and pay
too much for something and go crazy
getting some bidding war or something
out of control that's fine but um i
bought a house last october in the
middle of this
and so
you know uh yeah i mean
there's nothing wrong with that at all
and uh
but the big trick in this market is
don't be dealing with an amateur don't
be dealing with some kind of beginning
real estate agent get a
high quality real estate agent that
because this is not amateur hour i mean
you you want to have a pro in your
corner and just go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on elp for
a ramsey trusted endorsed local provider
for real estate they'll help you walk
you through this and i probably would if
i was living in a camper man i think you
understood that's what you said
and you may think that's comfortable i
got a feeling your wife isn't as
enthused as you are could be wrong
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book from
paycheck to purpose host of the ken
coleman show is my co-host today as we
answer your questions about doing work
you love
about building wealth and about creating
actual amazing relationships open phones
here
and triple eight eight two five five
two two
five
paca is going to start this hour off if
i can get the right dad gum number
pulled up here there we go in hawaii hey
paca what's up
hey how is it
better than we deserve brother is it
paca am i pronouncing that right
yeah that's right that's right cool how
can we help
well um
i kind of have a business in hawaii and
uh
i live in i live in southern california
i go back to hawaii
like once a month but
i had a competitor reach out to me that
wants to
you know buy my company
and um i don't know if i should
sell the company
and then you know i can go right up the
baby steps
and i'd be
pretty set you know what i mean but
i don't know if i should do that or not
because i've been kind of self-employed
i've been self-employed for
for a long time you know i mean so going
and working for somebody because there's
a job attached to
that
you know that that acquisition right how
long did they say how long they want you
to work for them
no i mean it's not so much how long but
like a couple years you know there's
some good money too that they want to
pay so
i don't know i mean maybe i should just
go back to so i have a house in hawaii
and then i have a house in southern
california my family's in southern
california i go back like next week i'm
going back to hawaii right now i'm in
southern california and i worked the
business
because hawaii was real bad with kovitz
so
we moved out to because i was working
kind of remotely so i moved out to
southern california and i just go back
and work the business and kind of work
remotely
and stuff so that's getting kind of old
with my you know me leaving my family
and stuff too yeah so that's why i'm
kind of tempted to you know maybe do
this deal um so i don't know just trying
to get some advice i i on all the boats
yeah i'm just curious
paint the financial picture for dave and
i if you were to sell okay and so based
on what you clear
uh how much they're offering to pay you
uh because there's no contract sounds
like on how long they want you to pay so
give us the financial picture short term
uh well basically they gave me a
proposal so it would be
about 2.2 mil um is what i would get and
then the job is like 150 to 200
depending
um and then uh you know with that money
after i paid taxes and everything else i
could pay the two houses off because the
two houses i own
i'm renting them right now because i'm
renting myself so i'm renting the two
houses for 4 500 each the one in
california is 4 500 another so i'll be
nine grand with those students cleared
and i'll probably be making like 12. how
old are you
i'm 36
okay so when you're 66 what do you want
to be doing
i don't know this business is really
stressful um i'm already
you know
i'm pretty stressed out about it
especially not doing it kind of remotely
too
but it does make money though i built it
i'm proud of it it's a part of me you
know that's why it's hard to would you
make on your profit
i pay myself a hundred thousand dollars
as a
employee and in the company
uh nets is a s corporation that i pay
taxes that pass through the knee to
about 300. the gross is about one one
do you want to stay in southern
california or stateside or do you want
to go back to hawaii long term
well what a job would be in hawaii
and uh you know the reason we came to
stateside was because the schools are
not that good in hawaii and i have three
kids and i'm married
i know that's why i asked you what do
you want to do long term do you think
you want to be in hawaii or do you want
to be stateside
yeah that's uh
yeah
i don't know um honestly i
you know i got out of hawaii because you
know hawaii is great it's a great place
but
i just like there's more opportunities
and you're a dog chasing his tail i'll
tell you your tone says you want to stay
out of hawaii your tone
your words don't say that your words
sound wishy-washy but your entire
posture i can hear it over the phone
means no hawaii and so i think another
option is these guys want this business
and you don't want to work it and you
don't want to go back to hawaii right
then didn't say hey give me the option
without me working for you see what they
say
i think you've got that
i could get a broker and uh just put it
on the block you know i think i don't
think you're gonna get this much for it
if it's making 300 grand it's not worth
2.2 if they're going to give you 2.2 you
cash on the barrel head for it
well it's the the way the industry works
they've um
it's a recurring monthly revenue
business
so
um
you know we have security agreements and
then they you know they're obligated to
pay that
so you know we have
how are you getting your money
up front and payments people that pissed
on the sale they would yes up front with
the holdback of like 10 or 15
after the first year
okay so you're gonna get 2.2 minus 10 or
15 percent and then you work there for
two years and you can control the whole
back by working there
towards the re it's the attrition of
losing the customers or not so we have a
base of customers that pass on a monkey
or but if there's hold back you could
lose the whole back and your job but
that's the worst case scenario
correct yeah all right and uh what do
you do for a living what's the business
it's a
security company so
we do fire
oh
okay
so you go sell the thing
and then you come to southern california
what keeps you from doing something else
with your life for the rest of your life
what do you want to do
i don't know if i want to do this
industry but that's just what i know you
know yeah but you know more than that
you're not limited to that industry
you're an entrepreneur you know how to
sell something you know how to serve
what you're selling yeah don't limit
yourself you know you you've got options
here but everything about you says you
don't want to do this long term so
i'm selling it i would too and i would
limit my stay on for one year
because i don't think you i don't think
it's worth 2.2 based on what you're
telling me
and
i'll take 2.2 gladly get out of dodge
work there one year get your whole backs
dropped and you can make you can by
working there you can make sure the
customers retain which is what they're
after and then you're done and you need
a freaking plan for what you do with the
rest of your life then
yeah
okay and you do need to think about that
but you're i think you're done with this
thing a you got a great deal b you don't
want to do it c you don't want to go
back to hawaii sell the stinking thing
all right now figure out what you're
going to do because you're only 36 years
old you're not exactly retiring on this
danny's got a house he can sell in
hawaii yeah since you're not going back
so that's he's got a good start i think
here's the quick advice for someone like
this
what did he enjoy about the work he's
done so far and then
we get a list of those things it's a
function issue okay i really like doing
this kind of work whether it's people
work ideal work process work thing work
right does the uh
survey help him yeah they get clear
career assessment hang on we'll give you
that yeah so you can kind of chart your
future and uh we'll give you that plus
the book paycheck to purpose the guide
up the mountain get clear
assessment you need that you need to get
clear
big time
hold on kelly will pick up
we'll give that to you as a gift
[Music]
so
[Music]
well if you've taken financial peace
university you know it's life-changing
but it's hard to watch your friends or
family struggle with money when you know
that there's hope that it can be done
now you can help them change their
family tree just like you did when you
give them a ramsay plus
gift card
it bundles everything that they need to
win with one money or win with money and
one gift
the gift card includes financial peace
university a year of the premium version
of every dollar and now we've also
included
an added
unlimited group coaching from our team
of financial coaches
so if you could pay for these separately
it would cost you over five hundred
dollars but for the month of may only
you can get a ramsey plus gift card
financial peace university every dollar
and coaching all included
just 99 bucks
that's known as a deal
this summer share the hope you've
discovered by giving a ramsey gift card
just visit ramseysolutions.com
gift
that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash
gift it's the easiest and best way to
give financial peace university
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day they've got a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsey to get the best deal
today's question comes from jennifer in
new york i'm a registered nurse and also
a new mom to a wonderful six-month-old
son currently i'm working my dream job
making 75 000 a year to speed up our
debt snowball i took a position as a
part-time travel nurse on the weekends
bringing home an extra 8 000
per month is that what that is but i'm
working 70 hours a week i left my dream
job for another travel nurse assignment
uh if i left my dream job for another
travel nurse assignment i'd make triple
my salary working just three days per
week should i leave on good terms to
raise my income accelerate the baby subs
and hope that my dream job company will
hire me back in a few years when i don't
want to do travel nursing anymore well
now you know uh this is a very personal
opinion here i don't know what dave
thinks but i would i would take the
opportunity now i think if you leave
well
and you explain why you're leaving
because of a very clear goal of getting
through the debt snowball and the baby
steps faster
nurses i mean we have a large amount of
nurses that have burned out and are
leaving the industry and so i don't
think that you're going to have a
problem getting back on with that
company down the line i would take the
opportunity now to knock out the baby
steps quicker
now very few companies have the policy
that we have at ramsey we almost never
rehire that's correct it uh we do but
it's very very very rare yeah 99 of the
time we don't
and uh because the reason you left is
the reason that you leave again and so
um
we don't we don't do revolving doors
around here but very few companies take
that stand
so um
you know that's the thing
you got to decide you know if the if you
couldn't get back on with that company
can you find something that looks a lot
like your dream job probably and i think
the answer is yes yeah i think you can
i think you can um the only thing i'm
worried about here ken is i mean
travel nursing with a six month old yeah
but it's only three days a week so she's
tripling her salary and only working
three days a week whereas right now
she's working 70 hours a week with the
main nursing job and traveling so she's
going gonna have more time with kiddo
triple the money speeding up the baby
steps you know look to me i'd take it
it's the opportunity to fast forward
some things and then
she's gonna have a lot of options yeah
the other thing is if you get out there
and you're miserable
you can look for a job that's correct i
mean i don't see any risk here it's not
permanent because travel nursing is
generally a temporary thing that's
correct most people don't make a career
out of that and that's part of the
industry is there's a lot of come and go
there are part of that part of the
industry
so to speak
so um
you know i've laughed over the years how
people have tried to call me in
uh the growth of ramsey solutions here
an overnight success
uh if you work your butt off for 30
years you're an overnight success right
and i've done enough stupid to know that
overnight success is too short and too
shallow to produce anything with
momentum and with meaning
and
a few years ago we developed a way of
thinking around ramsey called the
momentum theorem
focused intensity over time multiplied
by god equals unstoppable momentum i've
taught that lesson
in leadership settings all over america
and to business leaders and to
everyone else that the momentum theorem
it you know is how you create
unstoppable momentum i've taught it to
entre leadership
for years and i've talked to our team
matter of fact when you
get your uh when you do your first year
anniversary with ramsey uh we celebrate
by giving you a coin with the momentum
theorem on it that's how much we think
of this idea this is where momentum
comes from but you can have momentum in
everything not just your career not just
your business you can have it in
leadership and marriage and parenting
health finances faith and when you don't
have momentum
i mean that's why your life looks like a
country song you know i mean it's like
you are better than you look right then
and when you got momentum you're not as
good as you look because you look great
i mean when you're in the flow when
things are working and so momentum is a
real thing so we finally put all this
down our publishing team said i had to
do it and so i sat down and wrote a
ramsey quick read
which is a whole uh what is this thing a
whole 43 pages long
so uh you read it in what 20 or 30
minutes or something it's
it's a pamphlet literally i mean it's a
glorified pamphlet
but um
it uh but it's the momentum theorem is
out we just got them in
and you can get a copy of it at
ramseysolutions.com 10 bucks
and uh yeah it's um it's worth 10 bucks
for sure that's not a pamphlet that's
it's that says 43 pages of pamphlet but
i mean it's pretty thin ken look at that
there's not much there i can't believe
i'm arguing with you about the value
it doesn't matter it's a chalk full of
goodness 40 pages
there's one idea in there it's worth 10
freaking bucks okay but if you if you
think you're getting a deal out of it
for the thickness of it you're going to
be incredibly disappointed
because it's pretty thin this perfect
for 2022.
people don't want to read thick books as
much as they used to they still do but
not as much don't tell them well that's
what the data says that's perfect look
at that 43 pages to change your momentum
in any area of your life 10 bucks which
parts of your life are stuck and need a
big boost of mojo
see it's good marketing writing mojo for
10 bucks yeah oh hey there you go cup of
mojo that's what i mean
all right the momentum theorem is out
it's 10 bucks another ramsey quick read
enough of that silliness this is the
ramsey show
uh joseph's in woodland in the woodlands
texas hey joseph how are you
hey dave hey ken how are you guys doing
today great man how can we help
well sir first of all i want to say
thank you my wife and i got married
eight years ago we jumped on your plan
right away we uh we paid off 146 000 of
student loan debt we cashflowed three
cars have our emergency fund and 15
grand answer in the bank thanks to you
and a real bright future so thank you
very much
thank you
so my question has to do with babysit 3b
my wife and i currently rent a house
from our family for a discounted rate
just because they want to be a blessing
to us which we're grateful for
they've expressed to us that in about
three years when they retire they're
going to want to charge the full market
value for it and we're seeing that as a
window for us to start saving for a
house i just took a new job i'm making
about 91 000 this year it's base pay
plus commission so i think in my second
year and moving forward i'll make
between 115 and 130 a year so my
question is how would you
approach investing while saving would
you postpone investing while stockpiling
cash for a down payment for as much as
we can for the house
and just what would dave do
well we call it baby step 3b
when you finish baby step 3 and you have
your emergency fund before you start
investing in baby step 4
sometimes first-time homebuyers like you
will pause
temporarily
they're investing in order to save up a
down payment very very quickly
and that's an okay thing it's part of
the system that we teach if you choose
to do that sometimes people choose to
invest 15 and then just save the money
anyway for a down payment
uh so
i wouldn't go much longer than three
years but it sounds like you don't have
that as an option anyway
is everybody boot you out so uh it's a
good thing
yeah uh you know maybe put it on hold
for two years and see how big a pile of
cash you can come up with for your down
payment and then buy a 15-year fixed
rate uh mortgage where the payment's no
more than a fourth of your take-home pay
and that's a classic baby step three
b
scenario
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
alan and renu are with us on the line in
denver colorado it says on my screen you
guys are debt-free
congratulations thank you thank you
very cool how much did you pay off
a hundred and twenty two thousand nine
hundred and fifty six dollars
over nine years in our home that was the
final payout amount wow that's your
house and everything
house and everything yes sir
way to go
and your range of income during that
nine years
150 000 a year
okay very cool very cool all right good
good so tell me your story what happened
here
okay so
thanks we've been saving for our house
all along and been paying that down
rapidly but then we also i got an
inheritance for my mom and dad so
in order to honor them i used
a good part of that to pay off our house
okay very cool so you've made 150 along
the way the whole time
yes okay
so i gotta ask why did it take uh nine
years to pay off a hundred twenty three
thousand dollars making 1000. the
original
that would that was the loan balance at
the time
when i got the inheritance oh
i see
okay so that's the last chop of on the
tree
so what was what was the loan balance
when you started nine years ago
256 000. okay that makes more sense okay
so we paid off 256 000 over nine years
the final payment resulting from the
inheritance
yes
well i'm sorry for the loss of your mom
and dad
oh that's okay
it was it was their time thank you very
much wow
very cool so it's uh uh so what put you
guys on this journey tell me about it
i've been following you for 10 years
you've i've had the opportunity to meet
you a couple of times
he absolutely follows you he does all
the
cash envelope
system and that's what we have been
working on it and
and we we never have anything we never
buy anything on debt even cars if we
want to buy it we pay cash so you don't
buy anything on that ah fun okay good
good well it does sound like he's
following me then that's good following
what we think absolutely so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you've been doing this a long
time
to live on less than you make
and always make sure you're saving
something
stay out of debt
that's it not our friend that's it well
very fun
well congratulations who were your
biggest cheerleaders as you're going
along
well each other and
then my co-patriot on
i do the classes with oh you've been
leading financial peace university
classes
several of them yes
yes well thank you very much i bet
you're an incredible coordinator oh yeah
so i'm curious how much has the class in
leading those classes how much did that
spur you on because to take the house
out i mean that's a that's a big deal
and you've done it i'm just curious how
much that accountability and guiding and
instructing and encouraging others
helped you all get where you are
it uh made sure that we were that we
just stayed focused and kept working on
getting our house paid down and not not
getting in to any debt
it's that simple isn't it and
it's that simple
well done
very well done we've got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you
that is uh definitely the next chapter
and you got a story what's this house
worth guys
about eight hundred thousand now very
good and how much is in your retirement
investments
uh
about nine hundred 000. so you're worth
almost 2 million dollars congratulations
baby steps millionaire well done
thank you
feels good doesn't it
yes it does was it worth it
yes it is yeah good good every penny
well we've got a copy of uh babe of
total money makeover i'm sure you can
find somebody to give that away with the
classes and we'll also give you another
one-year subscription to uh
uh i'm sorry to ramsey plus to financial
peace university in every dollar and i'm
sure you can find a nice home for that
someone that's deserving and just to go
through the class so
uh yeah you can keep spreading the love
out there man thank you for teaching the
class and we're so proud of you guys
well done very well done
all right alan and renu in denver
colorado making a hundred are making 150
for nine years paid off 256 000 down to
123 and then knocked that out final lick
with an inheritance worth a couple
million dollars baby steps millionaires
they've been doing this stuff for a
decade count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're dead
[Music]
[Applause]
so proud of you
excellent work
wow that guy's a whole package yeah i
mean just done it all you know it's it's
amazing when you hear these stories of
folks that don't just get the baby steps
and live it out but then while they're
doing it they're instructing and guiding
others is one of our fpu coordinators
that's always special very cool andy is
with us in orlando coming i'm hitting
the wrong button every time here andy's
with us in orlando hey andy what's up
hi hello sir um i was actually calling
to say thank you
i found the dave ramsey show as a 14
year old high school freshman who had
recently moved to the u.s from venezuela
and that's whatever changed my life
i was a first generation immigrant
my parents were struggling financially
and i had no clue how to get into
college much less how to afford it
and i worked my way through it i found
scholarships and worked on breaks
i found my path with the dave ramsey
show and my goal was to go to college
for free and now i'm riding this forever
thankful doing better than i deserve
i recently graduated from cisco
university with a dual degree in diesel
arcs and business administration in
three years semiconductor and most
importantly completely deadly wow
good for you
you're on fire kiddo i'm proud of you
awesome
good work good work so how much of your
tuition to do debt-free to get a ba and
uh to get a business degree and liberal
arts degree how much of that was
scholarships and how much of it was hard
work from you getting a job
yeah so
well
for a year it's about
50 000. half of it i got to merge
scholarships and then half of it
a work study scholarship program that we
do community service with the community
and we work every week
and
they pay us for the week stuff like that
and then on top of that
also at jobs doing breaks and some other
jobs during specific semesters stuff
like that
um but yeah so i would say
uh 50 of it
uh completely merit scholarships 50 like
work study program scholarship and
work you're amazing yeah and 100 grit
yeah she's got grit yeah
50 scholarships 50 work and 100 grit
right i like it
andy you're amazing i'm so proud of you
what are you going to do what kind of
business are you going into
yeah so um it's
to build the green people arts and
business administration so i'm thinking
uh looking for a job for now in graphic
design
um
but yeah just looking for next options
right now next up with somebody yeah i
don't think you're gonna have any
trouble at all you are what's known as a
go-getter i'm so proud of you very very
cool hey thanks for calling in with that
story and letting people that know it
can be done
because it can be done
you know it requires a lot of
hoots
a lot of guts to lean in and go do that
stuff but here she stands a hundred
percent debt-free
uh with a degree yeah and uh
you know obviously we had a little bit
to do with it and we showed her how and
made her know it could be done but
that's a lot different than somebody
who's so lazy that they don't even think
about how they're going to pay for
school
and they just go sign up for student
loans and then they whine about the fact
they're 200 000 in student loan debt
like somebody did something to them
can't teach hunger she's hungry for a
better life she's hungry for a
contribution yeah and you can hear it
she's what les brown calls hungry that's
right hungry yeah you feel that a little
different this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today luke 6 31 however
you wish to be treated by others is how
you should treat everyone else
angela earhart said everyone talks about
building a relationship with your
customer i think you build one with your
employees
first
treat other people like you won't be
treated
it's pretty much our hr manual around
here we don't have much else in it
it pretty well solves most things and uh
by the way it'll help you with your
ethics class too that's correct is this
correct is this correct business ethics
would you want it done to you
would you want into you 10x
oh i think you just answered your
question
you know oh you mean you don't like
being lied to oh well there you go then
pride try not lying to people oh there's
a weird idea yeah oh you don't like
having stuff stolen from you oh well
then try not stealing stuff yeah it's an
interesting thing flip the thing and
walk up walk about a mile in somebody
else's moccasins you suddenly got your
dadgum ethics straightened out treat
other people
like you won't be treated
jesus said it and it works every single
time
bothersome sometimes though because some
people don't deserve to be treated as
well as i treat myself
isn't that the truth
yes oh i said that out loud i'm gonna
get hate mail for that one
oh well some of you people need to grow
a funny bone open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five ryan is
in portland oregon hey ryan welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for having me sure what's
up
so i have some friends that moved to
texas they've been pretty much telling
me all about you and i've been trying to
follow your youtube channel for last six
months
and they've been telling me i need to
sell my cars and i don't know if that's
the wisest decision and here's where i'm
at i own both of my cars i just got down
to owning both of these but i currently
have 17 000 in credit card debt i'm
trying to get come all down and i'm
about ready to have a 60 thousand dollar
student loan
stop stop stop you're about to have a
sixty thousand dollars how do you just
grow one of those when you're trying to
get out of debt
that's funny she's in school right now
and she's almost done with school and
that's the reason why i'm gonna oh the
loan's already there you just she's
about it's about to come due
yes oh okay that makes a lot more sense
okay they're telling me i need to sell
these uh cars that i own which i don't
know if it's the smartest decision
because now i own them both and they're
telling me i should sell them and try to
find something cheaper yeah are you
married i'm just kind of curious i am so
she is your wife okay good yes all right
and how much are the cars worth each
um i'd say my truck's probably between
10 and 13 and my wife's suv is probably
between eight and ten
okay and what's your household income
um right now since she's working
part-time it's about 110. okay what will
she be making when she graduates and the
student loans come to
i'm guessing she's going to be around
the 75 to 100. so you have a 200 000
household income give or take and that's
the coming this summer right
yes in august okay and you got a 60 000
student loan and 17 on credit cards and
a couple of cars worth around 20 grand
yes
i agree with you not your friends i
think you ought to keep the cars
you think i should keep the cars yes
okay but i think you need to bust your
butt and pay this debt off in less than
one year
less than one year i was shooting for
two but why you're making 200 right now
you've been living on 110 you're getting
rid of your income all the way to 200.
why do you have to spend it all you're
not in congress
no you're right uh my wife's uh very
passionate about we need to find a
different place to move we ran where we
are so
well so go rent something different
the price
and you're broke
you have no money
okay broke people who buy houses become
broker that's why they call them brokers
that make sense yeah please wait a year
go rent something else if you hate the
place you're in go rent something else
that you hate even more because renting
is temporary and get these get these
credit cards paid off and the student
loan paid off and keep your two cars
okay listen if you do part of this
advice it don't work
no i agree with you this is what i've
been following since i've been following
you for the last six months i've already
paid 10 000
of my debt off and i know if i want to
have talked to my friends in december
about this i would have been in more
debt and a loan than less
so i admired before we came up that's
before we came upon yours insistent wife
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
we need to follow this we need to do it
now and i'm like okay what do we do oh
oh she's insistent
oh yes okay but except for the part
about buying a house while you're still
broke right
you know she just wants to move whether
we buy a house or oh good i'm with her
i'm with her
it's really inexpensive because i've
been here so well
you're living in a gross place and she's
right
you're asking your bride to look at a
dump go rent something decent go go rent
something decent you make 200 grand yeah
i mean this place you were living in
there before you all got married weren't
you
yes i knew it it's a dadgum bachelor's
pad gross man
yeah i've been here for almost 13 years
oh it's really gross it's super gross
yeah she's exactly i can actually smell
it this woman this woman is smart yeah
yeah she's smart yeah you need to follow
her lead go get you a decent place to
rent for a year it doesn't have to be
the freaking taj mahal but it's just not
gross
and uh and then work your butt off and
get out of debt hey i like you guys you
all are fun thanks for calling in and
hold on i'm going to put you into ramsey
plus with financial peace university in
every dollar we're gonna pay for it for
the first year and get you guys in go
through that class go through every
detail
and i thought your wife was insisting on
buying a house that's why i was picking
on her and i misunderstood so i was
wrong so since i was wrong i'm going to
give you stuff free
so it's pretty cool it seems like that
often oh yeah and if you are you don't
admit it so this is a double whammy here
it's double double you know bonanza yeah
this is crazy folks somebody marked this
day down
yeah you know i think it's fun dave is
that the friends who are ramsey folks
were wrong said they were wrong but they
at least were aggressive you know
they're like sell your car yeah these
people are gazelle intense right now
they're they're like so the rule on
selling the cars is
if they're less than half your annual
income and you can be debt-free in under
two years not counting your house and
you like your cars you keep your cars
that's our rule
so the intense dave ramsey people were
not following the rule all right because
he's he you know he's got a hundred
thousand getting ready 110 000 getting
ready be almost 200 thousand dollar
income he's only got 20 000 worth of
cars so they're less than half and he's
only got 60 plus 17 77 000 in debt and
he could be debt free in a year
especially with her new income kicking
in and even with a higher rent because
he gets out of the gross 13 year old
bachelor pad
yeah it's a freaking science project you
have your wife living in oh yeah
it is really fascinating to know the
difference i've got two teen boys and a
teen girl and the living conditions that
men will put up with starts early my
boys basically live in squalor i'm
telling you in their bathroom versus
there are some ocd males but most males
will just live under a bridge they just
don't true i mean just get me a tent and
a grungy sleeping bag and i'm good
well i mean it's just it's and guys you
really have to be
reasonable with your with your wife i
mean it does make a big difference on me
being able to play long ball on this be
able to have a long term mentality and
keep playing through
and um
moral the story is guys don't let
gazelle intensity make it gross
you know there's nothing in your plan
that says gross is okay so this guy got
to keep his cars but he lost his
apartment that's the net of the phone
call that's true yeah not bad not bad he
came out pretty good in this and ramsey
plus and he gets and he got ramsey plus
and he got to keep his wife and she was
insistent about the proper things not
the improper things i think our work is
done here misunderstanding i think i
think we can just set that one down
good stuff good stuff
orlando uh i just got a report in we're
gonna be there thursday night there is
73 tickets left oh boy
so it is basically a sellout but you can
probably still get a ticket if you jump
on there right now orlando building
wealth is thursday night don't miss out
ramsey solutions.com events we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you